mais pour la pakistanaise malala
yousafzai cette attaque est un
douloureux rappel du combat à finir en
faveur de l'éducation des enfants
une cause pour laquelle elle a reçu le
prix nobel de la paix vraiment c'est
aussi cette cause l'éducation dont qui
lui a valu d'être elle même la cible de
ce groupe de talibans exactement le
moule à face de lui là à l'époque avait
demandé comment doute 80 d'aller tenter
de l'assassiner
ce fameux fazlullah maintenant et à
l'appel des talibans du pakistan
alors dites nous qui ils sont cette
année dans la d'abord une précision
aujourd'hui il ya eu un communiqué des
talibans d'afghanistan qui ont dénoncé
l' attaque contre l'école qu'indique
c'était contre les règles de l'islam
ça ce sont les talibans dont qui
combattait les canadiens en afghanistan
les troupes américaines canadiennes de
l'alliance il ya le mouvement des
talibans du pakistan lui s'est créée en
2007 c'est un regroupement de toutes
sortes de factions qui ont un but faire
du pakistan une république islamique
régi donc par la charia renversée sur le
gouvernement pakistanais
courteau beaucoup trop soumis aux
américains depuis donc 2007 destruction
d'écoles par centaines attentats par
centaines une guérilla qui a fait
jusqu'ici de 40000 à 50000 morts ça dure
depuis plusieurs années déjà cette
guerre civile mais là il ya eu un regain
d'intensité de l'attention et c'est ce
qui aurait mené à ces attentats
exactement
pendant des années le gouvernement
pakistanais hésité à les attaquer ces
gens là ces talibans dans leur base qui
est au nord waziristan nord ouest du
pakistan
parce que d'abord on avait peur des
représailles justement et aussi parce
que le nord-waziristan là c'est très
difficile d'accès c'est très montagne
coupée du reste du monde
mais ce qui est arrivé en juin dernier a
changé toute la situation attaques
contre l'aéroport de karachi 28 morts
choquée là vraiment ça a choqué
l'opinion publique pakistanaise
c'est la goutte qui fait déborder le
vase et là le gouvernement pakistanais
dans les jours qui ont suivi a lancé une
vaste opération 30000 soldats
pakistanais sont rendus au
nord-waziristan appuyées par des
bombardements aériens y compris des
drones américains
on aurait fait jusqu'ici 1800 morts dans
les rangs des talibans pakistanais
plusieurs se serait aussi sera au fût et
ailleurs dans le pays d'or
opération serait considérablement des
dérangés perturbé et c'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on se retrouver avec des
représailles contre une école d'enfants
de militaires pakistanais terrible merci
beaucoup
vraiment merci